all right juan one uh where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
from cleveland ohio cleveland and uh
tell me about your
your family growing up you had both your
parents i had both my parents for the
time being
uh maybe up until i was like nine or ten
i
had my mom and dad my dad eventually
just disappeared on us through
schizophrenia
he didn't want us to see him like that
so like your dad had schizophrenia yes
and he became homeless how bad was your
dad's
schizophrenia uh i said 10 out of 10. it
was the worst of the worst
um he would like to get to the point he
thought my mom was out to get him
he would beat burner uh
walked out into the living room one day
with my mom saw him with a gun to his
head butt naked on the floor
laid down um got to the point where
my mom had to take me to go see him and
downtown
cleveland because i haven't seen him
forever and i
saw him and he looked he's four maybe 43
and he looked like an 80 year old man he
wasn't the father i thought he was like
he wasn't it two weeks later after that
i got the news when i was at baseball
that
he had uh passed away due to a heart
disease heart attack on the street
you find him on the side of the corner
and uh
i don't know it's just like i had a
really good relationship with my dad
like every day
when it was it was just me and him
growing up like he wouldn't even
he would have a good relationship with
my sister but like
it was just like that guy thing like we
had a bond i felt it and like
we hang out every day and then like i
remember it and then i just got
to the point where he just left us and
and nothing i could've done about it
like you know just growing up i had
goals and dreams of
maybe making in baseball or something so
you're a baseball player
yeah how far did you go
i have three years of college under my
belt of associates degree
i was out of high school commend ohio
state played baseball 75
scholarship had uh scouts looking at me
i had texas ranger questionnaires out of
high school
like i could have done my thing but
i wanted to run around with friends and
not stay focused
um what position you play i'm a pitcher
pitcher
yeah hold it 22 22. yep
and drugs came into the picture um i was
always smoking weed and drinking with
friends it never really bothered me
because i was still doing good in sports
but then um my third year of college my
junior year uh
i met this guy at a bar you know we're
just having a good time kicking it off
and uh he took me back to his house
because we were just gonna chill
and um he pulled out some stuff and i
just thought it was just regular cocaine
or something
and it was a rock and then two seconds
later he pulled out a pipe i was like
you know you don't smoke
crack like cocaine like you don't do
that and then uh
he started smoking he starts crack and i
just saw him and just how he looked and
just
said he felt good and nothing he wasn't
worried about nothing like
he just let me get a hit and from there
on like
six months later i'm still doing it
trying to trying to break the code like
trying to get back into school and
baseball like this was just six months
ago
you tried yes sir six months yeah so
i caught it early but i gotta where
where is it taking you since
it's taking me homeless taking me
nowhere to go taking me not eating
not sleeping not talking to my family
um making my family worried sick about
me you came out to la recently
yeah for rehab and then i completed
rehab
and then uh i went to back to ohio
and they made me do um the rehab found a
sober living for me
so i flew back out here it's called
awakening
um went there i just i wasn't like a
normal sober living
so like i think i'm maybe being stubborn
or
not opening my mind to new ideas to
where i just
left and then i came back and i left
again
because and then i'm just right here
right now
trying to tell me about crack addiction
how how powerful it is
very powerful because just the way my
work head works i've battled depression
anxiety
suicidal thoughts like everything
and like the way crack works for me i
just feel like
it just clears my mind i don't think
about nothing like i have no worries
when i hit the crack
like it just makes me like
thoughtless because my head runs and
runs every day
about who i'm going to be in the future
or what i'm going to do or
how i'm going to be able to maybe take
care of my mom because she's done
everything in the world for me
and like that's my biggest dream and i
think that dream right there is just
killing me
as to how i can figure out to help her
and help her stop struggling every day
day in and day out
because i see how hard she works for us
three sisters
and he's growing up living with
cockroaches
going to bed to bed like it was just
different
and i don't know it's not that i'm
scarred it's just that
i want to break and break the curse to
where
i want to make it and i want to do
something for my family
and i want to be the one to provide and
because i'm the only man now
she just had gotten a divorce from um
my guy she was just with because he
turned out to like a 18 year old
and stuff and he told her that a week
later
and they got a divorce so now it's just
me my three sisters and my mom
and just listening to them talk to me on
the phone when i talk to them here and
there
just it's eating me up bad because
i'm not i'm not like this i'm not meant
to be here i'm not
this kind of person and the crack is
totally taking me a whole 180.
but how are you supporting yourself now
um
honestly like i have been
kind of selling my body it's not
something i've done
like i'm not bad i've had nothing but
girlfriends uh
girls all my life dude it doesn't i
don't enjoy it
no but it's common for guys that are
doing crack to use
their bodies to make that just to eat
and have that so that's how it's been
going
and i don't know i'm just ready for a
change
i'm really ready for a change dear
friends
i have a lot of friends back in
cleveland yeah they know you're out here
like this
yeah yeah it's it's
it's like you're stuck in quicksand
isn't it yeah but
my mom said once i get my id and
everything she'll fly me back home
because my illegal losses are stolen so
i've been working on that
she's uh mailing out my birth
certificate and stuff so i can have my
two forms
and once that gets going i'm maybe gonna
well i mean i have a plan to stay out
here
and go to college and play baseball
because the weather here in baseball
that's a good combination ohio's weather
is just
cold so like i don't know i have i have
a couple options my coaches know
people out here that they can get me
into the schools like
they have good connections so because i
have really good coaches
and your coaches know that what you're
going through as well yep they care
about me a lot
they really do they they have been the
father figures
in my life to be honest like i have
two two coaches that
are like a father figure in my life and
they're trying to guide me
and strengthen me like and their name's
rob mcnerney
and steve dinnerman and i love those two
guys to death
and i would do anything for them that's
great
what emotions do you deal with every day
going through this
i hold back a lot of tears um
a lot of anger
um i don't know yesterday was the first
day i just like
all day i don't know why like yesterday
was the day where
all the tears were coming out breaking
down like
my feet just like stress that hurt bad
like just for walking around trying to
find money like all day
like i don't know my feet kill
my head spinning like i don't know
i just don't have no a lot of fight left
of me and
i know i know i know god has me at the
end of the day
and i know he's going to make a way from
me but i have to take action on it
and i know i will i know i will
do you feel like what happened to your
dad kind of
that scarred me yeah sure oh yeah
i think about my past every day but i'm
trying to let go of the past
because once i let go of the past it's
going to set me free
it's going to let me prosper in life
it's going to let me be something
back to your childhood it sounded like
your childhood wasn't that awful right
god wasn't that awful it's just like
how things went like just my thing is i
i wanted a father in my life i wanted
somebody to
you know help me grow like teach me
things
but like just seeing how my mom
and everything what she had to go
through
and living how i live
it wasn't awful it was a struggle to
you know make ends meet because
my other my dad's side of the family
battles with addiction too
so like i'm just trying to break the
curse
i think what some people don't
understand is that addiction no longer
is a choice after you get addicted
it wasn't it maybe was a choice that
first time when that guy offered you a
crack pipe but
after that it kind of it's out of your
control it seems right
right well i don't know i just been
feeling lately like
i feel it's coming to an end i just got
to find
either a rehab a school or just
get back with my family like i just
those things have to happen and i'm
i think i'm gonna come to a night
because the life
i just don't like the life i'm living
it's not comfortable anymore it's not
it's not fun it's just painful just
brings pain
and hurt and misery
yeah to you and your family yeah that
really does
i'm sure your coaches and friends and
everybody mm-hmm
it's got to be hard for you to
it must cause a lot of guilt and shame
exactly
which makes you want to use more and
then it becomes a cycle
i feel like i don't know like i have a
big heart i think i do
like i like when i help others when i
see
others do good in my life that i know
like
i feel good like if i can do something
for you
something little anything like it makes
me feel good i just feel like
just people take advantage of that
sometimes and
that hurts me too even more yeah well
skid row is one of the worst places you
can find
exactly for human behavior you'll find
the worst of the worst here
yeah what the what would you say you've
learned
what valuable lesson have you learned
from this experience being scared
and homeless yeah and using cracking on
it you gotta
what i learned is you have to have a
good mental
a strong mental like a disciplined
muscle
and like i i can have that i used to
have that
i learned that it's really about mental
health isn't it exactly
yeah it's nice like you gotta you gotta
carry yourself good you gotta walk
like you gotta walk differently
to get to where you need to be it's like
everybody i feel like if everybody
wanted to in skid row
they can get out of here they can start
a new life
it's just like how disciplined do you
want to be how
how bad do you want it or like you know
you just got to do it for yourself at
the end of the day
if you're doing it for others then
you're not going to kind of get far
like just got to do it for yourself
all right juan well thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you and i
wish you the best of luck getting
getting out of here thank you getting
away from crack
you're still young yet so it'd be great
to get back to your baseball right yes
sir yeah
good good luck man thanks thank you